don't cross line oh god I want to cross
the line yeah leap of faith
you can't go first dumbass kids let's
see how many ways I can kill myself ha
[Applause]
okay don't go to dr. Todd alright let's
try this again with less suck how about
all [ __ ] I space to begin ok did that
begin I've gone backwards a little bit
ha ha this is it Oh Sami is going
terribly wrong with this creeper red
rope swing better than the green rope
swing pull upper body Frank's Booya
right it my 9
I'm just incredible better
all right you wits I'll take you order
two of you so I can take a hold of yours
Oh No Oh
[Music]
slender two pages
slender I don't know yay did I get one
no I did not hey it's no more muffin
here ah bloody sword throw weight first
to screen
no dammit right out of my rights
like a boss let me go I'm amazing
holy hell BMW BMW I don't give a [ __ ]
about cars ha ha sorry I give a [ __ ]
about cars
I'm sorry what have I done about cars go
forward please thank you just riding on
this conveyor with my face beyond sorrow
don't kill yourself
I'm Indiana Jones surf on neon
huh some magical adventure it's so
colorful and pretty and beautiful makes
me think that life is worth living and
the [ __ ] no I screwed up
stupid all the porn dad's that didn't
make it okay please please just one of
these I don't kill myself
got it got it ah yes ha ha yeah on a
roll here we go got a grab one gotta
grab one get up please
ah sorry battle yeah ha ha oh I missed
it just because I'll protect ya [ __ ] I
kill myself
oh it's gonna hire you I am proof oh you
think you can beat a fresh roll
technique you only hit my penis Oh her
dodge I do not require any of those I'm
not running I'm biking whee
[Music]
ramaa
oh yeah but you did not Wow Kappa Tau
Kappa Tau this is creative ha ha
[Applause]
okay all right this time I won't go easy
on ya huh oh ah no you come back here ah
my penis [ __ ] yeah God stop inflicting
my own desk ha ha I got you now ha ha ha
that job ha ha ha
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like what
your son you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel
I'll help the channel grow leave a like
add it to your favorites or share it
with your friends on Facebook and
Twitter
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]